yes
dominguez lanier we know you just came
out of a titanic game 108 moves i
believe uh you tried your best to win
this came this critical moment in the
game when you could have gone for the
end game by winning the b-pawn instead
you took on h6 and it turned into this
very turgid bishop of opposite color end
game
your thoughts on the struggle just
immediately coming off it fresh yeah
well of course
quite disappointing
because i felt that i was completely
winning and in fact uh i guess i was
but uh yeah after i mean my my first
intention in this position when i went
for this was to to play queen f8 takes
on e8 and takes on b5
and
should be winning
i mean i i saw that there was no
perpetual check
but then i saw bishop takes h6 and it i
thought it's just more simple i win uh
another pawn
but yeah maybe it was the wrong
practical decision i thought that after
bishop takes h6 king h7
uh maybe i can take on g7
yeah this was possible
king yeah king takes queen e7 king ha
king h6 takes on f6 26 25
yeah just put the queen on e5 and and
this also looks super winning because
it's four pawns and
bottom v2 is protected yeah
so
several ways to win
tough game indeed titanic struggle i
know you must be tired but to miss the
opportunity to be somebody like fabiano
it's got to be
yeah
it's of course uh disappointing but
on the other hand uh
he defended quite well i think after um
i played this h6 move i didn't like um i
mean i
um somehow i didn't realize that he can
just
wait with queen c6 and keep the pawn on
f6 i was thinking that g takes h6 is
force and then
the king is very weak that's why i went
for h6 but
i think in that position too if i play
g4 it should be
more or less winning but yeah in general
of course
it's uh it's a bit uh
disappointing to lose such such a chance
but uh but the tournament um is still
in the beginning so we have um nine
games more and it's important to
just
get back and play well well we
appreciate you spending time with us we
know it was a very long game we'll let
you get your rest and prepare for
tomorrow thank you